30 novembre 2016 à paris c'est
l'événement le plus sexy de l'année
ap
sur les paroles de the week end le
chanteur à la mode du moment
les anges de victoria's secret de mettre
le feu
[Musique]
c'est le défilé le plus cher de
l'histoire 19 millions d'euros
de plus
j'ai deux
la marque s'est offert les plus grands
mannequins
comme bella did adriana lima ou kendall
jenner
et des star internationale de la pop
bruno mars et même lady gaga
[Musique]
m
pour ce show hors norme c'est aussi le
lieu qui marque les esprits
un décor de rêve en plein centre de
paris
la nef mythique du grand palais
[Musique]
avec en moyenne 250 événements par an
c'est le lieu de toutes les
métamorphoses un mastodonte de 77 mille
mètres carrés toujours en mouvement
situé entre les champs-elysées la très
chic avenue montaigne et la cents
le grand palais a été construit en même
temps que la tour eiffel pour
l'exposition universelle de 1900 depuis
il a toujours accueilli les
manifestations artistiques les plus
impressionnantes de la capitale sous son
dos mythique de 13 mille cinq cents
mètres carrés l'équivalent de 13 terrain
de football toutes les folies sont
possibles propriété de l'état
toute l'année le grand palais passe aux
mains de locataires plus prestigieux les
uns que les autres
nous avons suivi les coulisses de ces
événements qui se déroulent
habituellement loin des caméras
comment en moins de 48 heures
l'imposante bâtisse en pierres se
transforme-t-elle en la plus grande
patinoire couverte au monde
pour son défilé chanel karl lagerfeld a
décidé de propulser le grand palais dans
un univers intergalactique
il a métamorphosé la nef en base
aérospatiale
le musicien pharrell williams et la
chanteuse lily allen sont aux premières
loges
c'est toujours spectaculaire est
incroyable ça va être un super défi les
avoir
d'une saison à l'autre le grand palais
change de peau il ravit les amateurs
d'art le temps d'une exposition où les
passionnés de concours hippiques
[Applaudissements]
avec les organisateurs et ceux qui vont
y vibre et le temps d'un événement
immersion dans le quotidien mouvementé
de ce palais aux mille visages
pour mettre en oeuvre les
transformations monumentale de ce lieu
mythique des centaines d'hommes se
relaient chaque année comme philippe ya
pire pour commencer sa journée d'accord
alors ça agréable une petite promenade
carte postale avant de commencer la
journée dans une belle carte postale
mais pour philippe la journée ne va pas
être aussi paisible qu'un décor de carte
postale
ce chef de chantier pas comme les autres
ne dispose que de 48 heures pour créer
dans la nef du bâtiment historique la
plus grande patinoire couverte au monde
on va faire le tour du chantier c'est la
troisième fois que l'entreprise
d'événementiel pour laquelle ils
travaillent organise cette grande
manifestation populaire c'est un frigo
j'ai rencontré sorte c'est une machine à
glaçons géante
sauf que l'on ne passe pas les glaçons
les gars n'ont enfin un grand glace ont
tous les deux ans philippe doit se
surpasser pour réussir ce défi technique
car la verrière du grand palais est une
gigantesque sert le moindre rayon de
soleil peut retarder la formation de la
glace pour être sûr qu'elles prennent
ces kilomètres de tuyau noir sont
alimentés par un liquide qui va geler
l'eau déposé en surface
[Musique]
ce liquide magique est propulsé par
d'énormes machines installées dans la
cour du monument sanaa le ron-ron faut
écouter les chante
elle dit qu'elle ait du courant c'est
bon pour toi ou phoques était un chef
électro qui viens de voir on est paré et
d'aplomb ok on va super génial sous les
ordres de philippe 50 techniciens qui
travaillent d'arrache-pied chaque minute
compte
une grande soirée d'inauguration est
organisée le lendemain les patins
viennent d'être livrés mais au moment de
créer la glace problème le liquide
magique ne sort pas
[Musique]
les techniciens se concertent pour
tenter de réparer la panne philippe est
inquiet car il comptait sur cette nuit
pour laisser prendre la glace et il est
déjà 19 heures enfants va pas si c'est
pas fini la seule urgence c'est finir
les équipes commencent qu'à arroser la
piste elles n'ont qu'une nuit pour
transformer la salle en banquise avec un
peu de chance on aura les pins grands
iront s'installer dans deux jours
philippe et ses équipes ne seront pas
les seuls à passer une mauvaise nuit
le lendemain matin à levallois perret il
y en a un autre qui n'a pas beaucoup
dormi
c'est olivier moret il a hâte de savoir
si la glace a bien pris car c'est lui
qui est à l'origine de ce projet fou
dans son entreprise d'événementiel
les salariés ont déjà tout prévu pour
l'inauguration
si le businessman est aussi attentif
c'est qu'il a investi une petite fortune
dans l'événement c'est plus de 2
millions largement qu'une demi heure
oui c'est ça de 2000 euros donc c'est
vrai que vous voyez il faut souvent
faire de la lisant entré autres manches
et souvent des pas bien olivier moret
dépensent plus de 60000 euros par jour
rien que pour louer à l'état
la nef du grand palais si la glace ne
prend pas c'est son investissement qui
risquent de fondre comme neige au soleil
ou alors il préfère s'assurer lui-même
de l'avancée des travaux
olivier morel espère accueillir ici plus
de dix mille visiteurs par jour pour
mettre un maximum de chances de son côté
il a prévu ce soir un gala
d'inauguration en grande pompe avec
patineurs professionnels ils n'ont que
quelques heures pour répéter sur place
leur représentation
comme un formidable bond là un gîte
larvaire bompard est comme un génial
à seulement 25 ans s'il ja et
pierre-loup ont déjà patiné dans les
lieux les plus incroyables de la planète
mais aujourd'hui sous la nef ils vont
glisser pour la première fois sur la
plus grande patinoire couverte au monde
il n'y a pas place
ils sont impressionnés par la majesté et
la réputation du monument
[Musique]
ça non ces motos pour être à la hauteur
du décor
ils ont prévu un numéro inédit
cinq minutes de chorégraphie avec un
final à couper le souffle
si l'aja aura les yeux bandés
[Musique]
c'est la première fois qu'il répète ce
spectacle aveugle une tentative pour le
moins maladroite
sylvia a visiblement blessé pierre loup
avec ses patins
tu voyais rien investi
mais le plus dangereux pour la jeune
femme c'est cette figure les yeux bandés
elle n'a plus aucune notion de l'espace
c'est quand même des choses très risqué
et la cie clc pu vous allez à la tête
qui tournait à louvres mauvais moment ou
alors je la pose et en fait elle
s'écroule c'est dangereux pour éviter
l'accident
pierre loup et s'il ja vont répéter
jusqu au dernier moment
19 heures les visiteurs sont déjà là
tous attendent de pied ferme l'ouverture
de la plus grande patinoire au monde
sans bien de voir un peu le décor du
grand palais avec de la glace en dessous
ça va être marrant on est équipé
l'entrée est à 25 euros mais même les
plus débutants veulent foulé la glace de
ce lieu magique
le grand palais art betty ses vêtements
d'apparat
la transformation est bluffante
ça va être génial tu aimerais tu hamiti
fois à quelques minutes de la
représentation le directeur olivier
moret veille à chaque détail
c'est parfait rempli pour vous coller
assembler un peuple doué 1 qu'est ce que
c'est que radhi nisme pardon mentougou
bon et moi là un jus d'orange plaît
sous les yeux des premiers visiteurs les
deux patineurs peuvent enfin inauguré
les lieux
[Musique]
cette fois ci même si cij a les yeux
bandés il exécute parfaitement leur
numéro
[Musique]
avec un final impressionnant
la tête de la jeune femme tournoi à
seulement quelques centimètres de la
glace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je requiers le bouquet et trimbach dans
ce ps
c'est maintenant aux visiteurs
d'investir la patinoire
lucie et kevin ont réservé leurs billets
sur internet depuis des semaines pour
être sûr de ne pas rater cette grande
première
c'est la première fois que la jeune
femme chose des patins attend tiens toi
tu vas y arriver c'est pourtant son
compagnon qui semble avoir le plus de
mal
attention
mais ces bons tranquille dans trois
minutes à un triple axel
le grand palais scintille de mille feux
avec ses jeux de lumière le monument
prend des allures de discothèque
en quelques minutes les jeunes visiteurs
en ont pris possession
[Musique]
il ya vraiment le lieu
toute façon
fallait pas louper je pense celui là
pour toute l'équipe en charge de la
patinoire le pari est réussi
philippe le chef de chantier admire son
oeuvre olivier moret lui aussi est
soulagé le businessman est l'un des
anges gardiens du palais
car ici il ne s'est pas contenté
d'investir dans la patinoire il a sauvé
une partie entière du bâtiment le grand
palais est aujourd'hui considéré comme
l'un des monuments phare de la capitale
pourtant ce joyau de pierre et d'acier a
failli plusieurs fois être détruits dans
les années 60
son style est très critiquée et son
entretien coûte cher pendant des années
cette aile situé à gauche de l'entrée
principale est laissé à l'abandon
pourtant elle a bien des atouts avec ses
colonnes impérial et son entrée
majestueuse olivier moret envoie tout de
suite le potentiel il remporte un appel
d'offres de l'état et y installe un
restaurant à la mode ce qui le séduit le
plus à l'époque c'est la terrasse de 300
mètres carrés
je voyais ce sol qui était incroyable de
mosaïques pseudo romaine revisité à la
fin du xixème et il y avait sept
feuilles mortes et j'avais dit c'est ça
doit être en février mars je dis mais il
faut ouvrir ça l'était on va faire un
espace très éphémère pendant deux trois
mois l'été les gens seront ravis de
venir
son style beaux-arts attire aujourd'hui
le tout paris certains viennent même de
très loin pour visiter sa terrasse à
l'image de ces américains pensaient de
l'endroit ici j'adore
pourquoi regardez comme c'est grandiose
ça me rappelle le dieu paris
l'été le soir c'est incroyable parce
qu'il ya un espèce de vent un peu frais
c'est inouï éphémère à sa création
le restaurant est désormais ouvert toute
l'année et pour obtenir une table à
l'heure du déjeuner mieux vaut réserver
[Musique]
4 en six ans d'existence le restaurant
du grand palais est devenu l'endroit où
il faut être vu
notre préférence en a 3 devant les
fenêtres et on propose pour une
réservation soit de 5 ou 6 personnes
éventuellement ce que vu que forcément
on peut pas servir en terrasse c'est la
petite solution qu'on propose à nos
clients de déjeuner devant la devant la
fenêtre un restaurant au coeur de l'un
des monuments phare de la capitale avec
cet emplacement stratégique
olivier moret espère attirer encore plus
de gourmet du monde entier sa stratégie
faire de son établissement une vitrine
de la gastronomie française
alors il a embauché un chef prometteur
stéphane d'aboville 36 ans formé par
eric fréchon le célèbre chef étoilé du
bristol un palace parisien
lui aussi a de très grands projets pour
les cuisines du palais service laissait
d'être un soir c'est chic déjà le lieu
fait qu'on ait restaurants chics et les
produits qu'on utilise se qualifier de
restaurants chics en moyenne ici c'est
30 euros le plat plus cher qu'une
brasserie traditionnelle aller avec des
potimarrons c'est bon
les clients les plus prestigieux peuvent
privatiser le restaurant c'est le cas ce
soir
il ya une commande spéciale pour toute
l'équipe du défilé dior truffe omar les
mets les plus raffinés sont au menu
donc ça c'est le var pour dior et dans
leur assiette à eux nous ont demandé
d'avoir leur assiette dresser l'oma avec
l'impossible de fenouil à la vanille le
homard breton et une vinaigrette niel
vous regardera stars internationales
gotha de la mode homme d'affaires avec
cette soirée l'enjeu est important
alors olivier le patron vient lui même
goûter les plats et les assiettes et
avoue à demi la petite feuille de salade
vous aviez vous la vouliez pas vous avez
suivi mes conseils fin gourmet le patron
semble très satisfait de cette nouveauté
au sérieux et il n'en est pas à son
premier test car ce type de repas il en
organise très régulièrement
c'est bon
non c'est parfait un délicieux là on va
en avoir un pour dior et un grand défilé
dior dans le donnent grand palais pour
chanel on a fait des trucs incroyables
et soirée où tout le le mini palais a
été transformée de boîte de nuit
invraisemblable des grands des
genévriers on vit au rythme des gens qui
sont dans le grand palais pour le moment
les cuisines du monument font le plein
le restaurant affiche toujours complet
le grand palais un monument sauver de
l'oubli grâce à des passionnés comme
olivier moret mais aussi d'autres
artistes à l'imagination sans limite
avec ses 77 mille mètres carrés et son
immense coupole de verre
la bâtisse est à la hauteur de toutes
les extravagances et celui qui a décidé
d'exploiter au maximum ses possibilités
c'est karl lagerfeld
il y à 11 ans il est le premier à y
organiser un défilé depuis le pape de la
mode
s'amuse à y casser les codes en 2015 le
créateur installe un lion géant de 20
mètres de hauteur sur son podium en 2014
il recrée des rues de paris et met en
scène ses mannequins dans une ambiance
manif à chaque défilé
les images font le tour de la planète
comme ce supermarché reconstitué sous la
nef c'est aujourd'hui qu'a lieu le
défilé 2017
mais personne ne sait encore ce que le
maître a imaginé c'est top secret même
pour son plus fidèle mannequin baptiste
giabiconi
[Musique]
à 27 ans c'est la star des podiums un
chouchou des médias qui multiplient les
shootings photos comme ce matin où il
fait la couverture d'un magazine de mode
son succès fulgurant il le doit au grand
palais le jeune homme a fait ses
premiers pas de modèles sous la voûte de
ce lieu mythique
un défilé qui a fait exploser sa
carrière c'est incroyable de trois
semaines auparavant d'être dans les
castings que ça soit milan a sillonné un
petit peu l'europe avec des moments pas
toujours évident avec des moments de
galère de doute et de se retrouver trois
semaines après la la détourner des gens
s'intéressent donc cesser c'est juste
whaou
aujourd'hui baptiste va participer à son
dixième des filets sous la nef pour lui
c'est devenu un rituel incontournable
j'aime me sentir bien dans les endroits
et je trouve que le grand palais il ya
quelque chose il ya une bonne énergie
voilà je ressens les énergies les trucs
c'est positif on peut se passer que des
bonnes choses là-bas pendant la fashion
week
cet événement attire le monde entier
tous rêvent d'y assister
mais seuls quelques privilégiés y sont
invités des centaines de personnes se
sont regroupées devant l'entrée du grand
palais simples curieux ou professionnels
de la mode à l'intérieur des vip par
dizaines le musicien pharrell williams
immortalisent l'instant
la chanteuse rita aura la réalisatrice
sofia coppola
l'actrice ludivine sagnier ou encore la
chanteuse lily allen
tous attendent le top départ du show
deschanel caylar la surprise totale le
spectacle et la joie ça sent très joyeux
c'est toujours spectaculaire est
incroyable ça va être un super défi car
cette année encore karl lagerfeld a vu
les choses en grand une base
aérospatiale en plein coeur de la nef
sous la verrière
il a installé une fusée de 37 mètres de
hauteur l'équivalent d'un immeuble de 15
étages un défilé hors norme au cou
confidentielles sur le podium c'est au
tour de baptiste le couturier a réservé
une dernière surprise à son public
personne ne s'y attend mais la fusée va
vraiment décollé
[Applaudissements]
vingt minutes après la fin du défilé le
mannequin vedette du couturier n'en
revient toujours pas juste magnifique
m
qu'est ce qu'on peut ajouter cet
événement d'une quinzaine de minutes a
nécessité des semaines de montage mais
après le show il faut faire
immédiatement place nette
car une autre manifestation est prête à
prendre sa place
et cette fois ci elle va occuper toute
une partie du quartier
en 1901 le grand palais avec une
vocation surprenante celle d'accueillir
des courses hippiques
au fil des années ces grandes
compétitions étaient tombés en désuétude
mais il ya huit ans la prestigieuse
maison hermès a décidé de les remettre
au goût du jour
ce matin c'est le premier jour de
l'événement que la marque a baptisé saut
hermès sur les champs-elysées les
chevaux ont pris la place des touristes
une immense écurie a été installé dans
ce jardin d'habitude ouvert au public
pour accueillir les 120 chevaux qui vont
s'affronter pendant les deux prochains
jours
la marque a fait appel à des sous
traitants habitué à organiser des salons
plus classique
geoffroy de thoisy et ce matin le chef
des écuries ses chevaux valent des
fortunes les débarquer pour lui un
moment très délicat
on sécurise surtout par rapport aux gens
autour de ce n'est pas des gens qui
viennent les toucher les voitures voyait
beaucoup beaucoup de véhicules qui
passent donc ce qu'on fait cette
enveloppe véhicule geoffroy doit ensuite
les installer dans leurs boxes
individuels
attention mais il cherche encore ses
marques
[Musique]
pas facile de s'y retrouver dans ce
dédale d'allées les français c'est ça
[Musique]
bienvenue si vous voulez du foie si vous
voulez des cocos sa disposition
voilà mes aveux si les chevaux sont
traités avec autant d'attention c'est
que cette compétition accueille les plus
grands champions simon delestre et le
numéro un français du saut d'obstacles
le 6e mondial le cavalier veut à tout
prix gagner cette compétition car dans
l'écrin du grand palais la victoire sera
d'autant plus prestigieuses
aujourd'hui il est arrivé en avance pour
être le premier à fouler le parcours
c'est la huitième fois qu'il participe
au saut hermès voir ce monument
historique
métamorphosé en pistes équestres lui
procure toujours une émotion très
particulière
[Musique]
c'est toujours un concours un peu
particulier de par l'endroit qui est
vraiment incroyable est vraiment un
solide pour faire du concours entrez ici
avec les chevaux c'est vraiment quelque
chose de formidable
la marque de luxe organisatrice du
concours a fait venir 1200 tonnes de
sable et construit des gradins pour les
seize mille visiteurs du week end
ce que simon n'avait pas prévu en
arrivant si tôt c'est que les ouvriers
seraient toujours à pied d'oeuvre
son cheval semble désorienté et a dû
mourir ils sont en train de monter
autour
et c'est vrai que là quand c'est calme
et d'un coup il tape avec un marteau ça
les salles et saisit toujours un mauvais
présage pour le favori de la compétition
le lendemain c'est le début du concours
pour assister aux épreuves
il faut payer 110 euros pourtant sous la
nef plus de quatre mille passionnés sont
venus assister à cet événement
exceptionnel
parmi eux de très jeunes supporters
comme sébastien satan passionné de
chevaux il connaît par coeur tous les
noms des cavaliers son objectif enrichir
sa collection d'autographes préparait
comme un pro il a même apporté son petit
carnet
mais bon
ça fait tous les autres il sera même il
te manque quelqu'un telle est la paix
montrez pas question pour sébastien de
se passer de l'autographe de la
médaillée d'or par équipe aux derniers
jeux olympiques
[Musique]
suivi par d'autres jeunes admiratrices
le petit garçon s'offre une course
poursuite dans les coursives du grand
palais et finalement la championne se
prêtent au jeu pour un sébastien un
petit peu intimidé
c'est pour lui une grande victoire
15 heures place aux choses sérieuses
pour les quarante sept compétiteurs
cette année le chef de piste du concours
a conçu un parcours particulièrement
difficile
[Musique]
tous les plus grands cavaliers buts sur
les obstacles simon part favori pourtant
le français ne va pas échapper à cette
malédiction
il s'élance l'épreuve commence bien mais
sur son dernier saut il fait une erreur
son assistante et première supportrice
comprend vite que le grand prix ne sera
pas pour cette fois avec il ya une
droite du coup c'est
le grand gagnant de cette journée c'est
finalement sébastien le petit chasseur
d'autographes
grâce à ce concours il a pu découvrir
les coulisses du grand palais et
approcher ses idoles
et justement il vient de repérer l'un de
ses cavaliers préférées simon n'a pas
gagné mais il a le droit à une
récompense inestimable l'admiration de
ses fans
à tort
si la nef du grand palais voit défiler
des manifestations spectaculaires comme
celle ci ce sont d'autres types
d'événements qui attire le plus de
visiteurs
février dernier ce matin là les équipes
du grand palais attendent une livraison
de la plus haute importance dans ce
camion une véritable cargaison d'or à
l'intérieur des normes qu'est-ce qui
abrite des tableaux de maîtres parmi les
plus cotés du monde
[Musique]
le moment est délicat
pas question d'endommager l'un de ces
trésors marque gens sont 36 ans est l'un
des commissaires de la grande exposition
jardin à laquelle les oeuvres sont
destinés il retient son souffle
tout le monde doit être bien concentré
parce qu'une erreur peut vite être avoir
des conséquences assez dramatique c'est
des tableaux de grand prix de grande
valeur les toiles sont gigantesques
cette pièce mesure trois mètres de haut
impossible de la faire passer par
l'entrée principale
alors c'est avec l'aide d'une grue que
les techniciens espèrent la faire
rentrer par la fenêtre
le tableau s'envole dans les airs après
dix minutes de manipulation il parvient
tout de même à rejoindre les murs de
l'exposition dans la galerie du monument
parisien ce sont 450 pièces qu'il faut
accrocher les nénuphars de monnaie ce
picasso des années 30
ou encore cette fresque de pompéi
peintes il y à deux mille ans c'est avec
ce genre de manifestation que le grand
palais accueille en moyenne cinq cent
mille visiteurs par an et d'autres
événements au retentissement planétaire
comme le tournage actuellement de
mission impossible 6 avec tom cruise